la sécurité des cartes bancaires en
question nous vous en parler on désire
le gouvernement se veut rassurant mais
certaines entreprises proposent déjà
larmes anti-fraude la société cybercom
va mettre en vente un boîtier qui permet
de faire ses achats sur le net en toute
sécurité
explications de lionel coutu et stéphane
taponier bienvenue chez cybercom c'est
grâce à cette société que les paiements
sur internet devrait être sécurisé
comment très simple au moyen d'un
lecteur de cartes comme chez n'importe
quel commerçant mais là le petit boîtier
vous l'aurez chez vous bah j'ai acheté
un cd rom qui m'indiquait 115 francs 26
on me dit à céret votre carte dans le
lecteur la transaction sur le net se
passe comme n'importe quel achat il
suffit de faire votre code
mais nouveauté le site internet ne
connaîtra jamais votre numéro de carte
l'opération va quitter mon lecteur prend
les devant mon pc de mon pc albanais sur
l'ordinateur du commerçant même avoir
passé la transaction comme un train il
ne pourra rien faire et la banque du
commerçant à voir passer la transaction
mais comme un train elle ne pourra rien
faire seul votre banque pour avis oui
c'est bien une transaction de monsieur
sitruk et donc je donne mon accord pour
le paiement et laurent mira la formation
au commerçant disant d'accord
jusqu'au jour où les pirates du net
arriverons à faire dérailler le train
tout l'enjeu est là
les partenaires financiers de cyber
comme en sont d'ailleurs conscients
aujourd'hui silure com offre la
meilleure solution qu'on puisse imaginer
actuellement termes de sécurité
bien sûr et ce ne sera pas vrai pour
l'éternité donc il faudra que nous
soyons capables au fur et à mesure où
les techniques évolueront de faire
évoluer aussi sévère coop et ça c'est
prévu prévu peut-être mais les pirates
peuvent aller très vite
en attendant le 18 avril prochain vingt
mille petits boîtiers seront disponibles
dans le commerce
coût pour le consommateur environ 400
francs